archaeologists announced they had
unearthed the oldest Homo Sapien remains
ever discovered analysis reveals the
fossils date back about three hundred
and fifteen thousand years making them
more than 100 thousand years older than
those previously thought to be the
oldest the history altering fossils were
found on a hillside in the Moroccan
desert researchers recovered skull
fragments teeth and other bones from
five individuals along with stone tools
and evidence of fire usage the discovery
reveals that the bone structure of these
early humans faces are not much
different from ours
to me it's quite striking is that the
reason why we connect these people to us
is their face the way they look so it's
people we would recognize like us if we
would cross them in the street the
fossils also changed the way we think
about where early humans developed they
were discovered on the western edge of
the African continent thousands of miles
away from the so called cradle of
humanity in Ethiopia the site where the
former oldest human remains were
unearthed challenging another
fundamental idea that our species
evolved in just one location you know
it's so fascinating how much we don't
know about ourselves right very exciting
all of this imagined stumbling on that
I'm struck at how good their dental work
is missing teeth no good job Homo
sapiens of Morocco